den menschen den spiegel vorhalten
die kuratoren der biennale reißen den
gängigen design begriff auf und
verstehen unter design alles was der
mensch auf diesem planeten gestaltend
mit ihm veranstaltet hat im lauf von
200.000 jahren wir gestalten die welt
seit beginn der menschheit und mehr als
das design verändert uns als wir
anfingen schuhe zu tragen begann unsere
ziehen zu verkümmern
unser physischer körper veränderte sich
der mensch als sein eigener designer
gestaltungskraft die bis weit ins
weltall hinaus und tief in herz und hirn
bringt die kuratoren konfrontieren uns
mit den großen fragen und globalen
problemen tolle tische lampen und
schnittige stühle sucht man hier
konsequenterweise vergebens wen
interessiert ob seine kaffeetasse von
aldo rossi dieser entwurf
wenn menschen leiden was wenn das leiden
selber designt wurde
mehr als 200 architekten künstler und
designer aus 50 ländern haben sie
eingeladen mit ihnen die dunklen seiten
von design zu beleuchten
unter ihnen die designerin mitschnitten
aus detroit
sie inszeniert hier in ihrem labor
dritter desaster eine glitzer
katastrophe glitter ist
unkontrollierbares material es wandert
von einem ort von einer substanz zur
anderen
es klebt an der haut gilt als sinnbild
für glamour
gutes design das sich wie ein
gefährlicher virus verbreitet sich
zitierend über die gesellschaft liegt
eine reflexion über die psychische
auswirkungen von design in den usa
wer ein problem mit dem individualismus
wir sehen darin die lösung für alles
aber gutes design kapsel das individuum
ein in einem scheinbar sicheren umfeld
das aber eigentlich überhaupt nicht
sicher ist auch aus den usa ein
architektenpaar dass die welt als eine
einzige stadt mit acht milliarden
einwohner versteht sie erforschen die
urbanisierung der band visualisieren den
abdruck den die menschheit auf dem
planeten hinterlässt ob es passagen sind
auf denen wir die ozeane überqueren oder
verschiedene flugbahnen den wir entlang
reisen all die wege die wir zurücklegen
die uns miteinander verbinden
das ist die spur menschlichen suisse
der blick auf die globale vernetzung als
chance das ist vielleicht eine etwas
naive position aber eine die von
optimismus an getriebe lässt weil wir
uns selber ermächtigen mit mehr
verantwortung zu handeln
die menschliche spezies untersucht sich
selber und lernt von sich selber
der türkische videokünstler annikas
musiziert in seinen arbeiten
menschliches handeln als solches er will
sich nicht auf sein land reduzieren
lassen und dieses nicht auf eine einzige
problemzone
natürlich haben wir probleme aber es
gibt kein land das keine probleme wir
leben in einer sehr sonderbaren zeit
ich glaube wir haben das schlimmste noch
nicht gesehen aber jedes land hat eine
schwachstelle muss verlässlich ist
das ist eine der großen design
metropolen und es ist eine stadt und
eine nation in der krise und das ist der
richtige moment um über design
nachzudenken
da geht es nicht darum in mailand london
oder new york einen espresso zu trinken
und darüber nachzudenken wie geschmeidig
design ist das ist wirklich ein was zur
hölle ist design moment ein statement
mit besonderer dringlichkeit im kontext
dieses landes im ausnahmezustand